well i think this is both for me
personal you will remember i lost my
uncle to uh covert we couldn't visit him
in hospital we couldn't have a proper
burial phone because of the restrictions
and of course it's very public because
i'm
such a state for education i'm part of
the team
that
delivered the vaccines um of course
and i think the prime minister
understands the level of hurt um in the
country um
for people sacrificed
people
missed loved ones who they can't turn
the clock back on he said it
dispatch box that i wish i could turn
the clock back and go back to that 20th
of may in the garden he spent 25 minutes
um
to what he perceived to be a you know
supporting his staff and encouraging
them and he wishes he hadn't done that
he wishes that he'd said look get back
to your desk because this is wrong i
hope i by the way i say this sincerely i
hope that i watched kirsten's interview
yesterday with sophie rayworth that he
also apologized i think it's only right
yeah i will deal with that of course but
i'm just saying that
we all have a duty uh to do the right
thing i think what the prime minister
has said we've had the apology now we
need the details and sue gray will
take her evidence and conduct her
inquiry and report swiftly and the pms
that he will submit himself back to
parliament uh to a statement and be
questioned on that and i think that's
the right thing to do i think that is
the fair thing to do
um so i hope people will will
allow him
the ability to respond to a thorough
inquiry by a very senior civil servant
reports over the weekend two people have
come forward to say that they personally
warned the prime minister that the email
invitation said that it was a party and
it shouldn't go ahead he says that's not
true why do you believe him
because i think he's absolutely right
when he says it's not true because i
think
ultimately um the
sugray investigation will be able to
look at all that and he's obviously um
submitted himself to that investigation
and sue gray as i know the civil service
and how
they will conduct their inquiry it will
be thorough in terms of
looking at emails looking at
correspondence looking at everything uh
and i think it's important that that you
know she does that but it's not true
that the prime minister knew about this
he implicitly thought this was a work
event he went from i think six
pm to 625 and then back to his desk and
i think it's only right that we wait for
we know the facts don't miss we know
that there were trestle tables with
peanuts and goodness knows what else we
know that there was booze we know that
at the time only two people could meet
socially distanced uh outside people
were literally putting their hand on
glass at uh care homes because they
couldn't go in to see their loved ones
you know the prime minister wants us to
believe that he spent 25 minutes having
a drink and thinking it wasn't a party
all i can say to you is i completely
understand how people feel angry about
this i think the prime minister some
pictures from this this was one of the
constituencies over the weekend people
have got lies written all over not that
one the other one i will come back to
that one in just a second this one
they've got lies written all over their
constituency offices
and as i
said
that is not the anger and the level of
of hurt is not lost on me or my family
or anyone so i absolutely share that all
i would say is
we have to allow the investigation to
take place why because that's the fair
thing to do you you don't condemn a man
um
without a thorough investigation i think
sue gray will conduct that and will
report that the famous woman in britain
at the moment isn't she everybody's
saying her name what about this this was
obviously a cartoon in the evening
standard
reflecting on her majesty sitting on her
own the day after the doors were coming
off number 10 people breaking swings
taking a suitcase to get booze
having a dj in the basement
come on and that is one of the most you
know the the the photographic image um
was one of the most painful images i
think um that will endure
with all of us with the nation for
anyone who's lost anyone who's lost
loved ones as
the nation's families have done up and
down the country i don't i can
absolutely
say to you that the prime minister feels
the pain which is why he came to
parliament delivered an apology said he
was or he asked afterwards and you say i
didn't really shouldn't really have
apologized but sometimes you just got to
do it well that's not
that's hearsay in reporting that's not
true that's not the prime minister that
that i've spoken to um someone who i
trust implicitly told me that he'd had
that conversation with the prime
minister well
look
if that someone is prepared to come on
your show and talk about it all i can
say to you is i've spoken to the prime
minister and i know
how much
he recognizes the pain and that people
went through and which is why he
apologized and he came forward and said
look i'm sorry um
just allow this investigation take place
that's all he's asking and then he will
submit himself to parliament um with a
statement to be questioned and well i
wish he misled parliament should he step
down all right well first of all let's
wait for the investigation i think it's
only it's only right here remember
our british values are all about you
know fairness and you don't condem an
individual before having all the facts
before you
the the thing that that you and i both
know is that he's apologized and i hope
other politicians do the same thing when
they've actually done something come on
i'll speak to them uh about it one of
the other suggestions that was made by
some of the backbenchers over the
weekend was if the prime minister is so
confident that he's got the support of
his party why doesn't he put himself up
for a vote of confidence and see how it
goes
well first of all your
prime minister
that's not how we um you know operations
happened before in well
you say that but but the prime minister
i think you know has every right to
focus on the job we've got a big
leveling up agenda we've got a leveling
up white paper which my department has
been contributing to to make sure that
you know things like literacy numeracy
leveling up is all about human capital
and education is they're leveling up
department so we're doing tremendous
work in that area you're going to hear
more from me on this you're going to
hear more on you know what we're doing
on the cost of living 4.2 billion pounds
to help people with the cost of living i
know it's something that that you know i
think sky and other channels have been
running today the the the help we're
doing
in april you get nine pounds 50 for the
national living wage where
you you know moving the taper for people
on universal credit to help them with
the cost of living all these things are
what the premises focus on at the moment
that is the right thing to do and i
think it's right to that he apologized
and he's right that he says look
i will submit myself to parliament once
sue grey is reported with all the facts
and i think you'll find
that
that is the the the way we conduct
ourselves so the week after next i think
is when we're going to hear from her
right she can she can obviously she's
she's doing it swiftly of course which
is tricky well the but the civil service
as you know and and this is a civil
servant the highest uh your level of
experience and uh integrity and i think
it's only right that she can take the
evidence wherever it leads and she has
everybody to do that